>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> All right.
Welcome, gentleman.
My name is Todd Harvey,
I'm a curator at the
American Folk Life Center
at the Library of Congress.
I want to thank you for
joining us this afternoon
after your concert,
after your lunch.
You're all refreshed.
I'd first like to introduce John
Cohen and the Down Hill Strugglers
so that we in the future
know who everyone is.
This is, from left to right, Eli
Smith; John Cohen in the jacket;
Jackson Lynch in the white shirt;
and Walker Shephard on the end.
These are the Down Hill Strugglers.
Today September 25, 2015.
And we're here in the
Coolidge Auditorium
in the lovely Jefferson building.
I want to thank you for the concert.
I want to thank you for agreeing
to move your concert to today
to accommodate the Pope's visit.
John, I understand the Holy
Father himself reached out to you
to ask you if you would change
the date of your concert.
He's a big [inaudible]
fan, I know that.
>> He's from Latin America.
>> They didn't want members of
Congress to have to make a choice,
and so we graciously moved aside.
And what an amazing
concert you all gave today.
>> Thank you.
>> I just wonder how you found the
acoustics in the room today, Eli?
>> Yeah. Well, thank you.
It was a really fun concert.
And the Coolidge Auditorium
has amazing acoustics.
It's one of the best places
I've ever played I think.
>> What about you, Jackson?
You've got a loud kind
of fiddle style,
and I wonder if you
could hear yourself.
>> Oh, yeah.
I wish I could play in here
with nobody else in here.
It sounded really good.
>> Yeah, sorry about that, man.
>> Sorry, we exist, yeah.
>> But you're talking
about the audience,
with the audience being gone?
>> Oh, I just mean I could
sit in here for hours
and just play by myself, you know.
>> What does it compare
to in different halls?
Well, can you think of any
halls that it compares to?
>> It kind of sounds like a
dance hall, a big dance hall
where the room sound travels really
well and everyone can hear it like,
in the back the same
as in the front.
>> We've played in
some old halls touring.
>> And I guess it does in a way,
it reminds me of that a little bit.
I remember that opera house in
Upstate New York a few years ago.
>> Yeah. It just has
a big sound like that.
>> Didn't we play in
a GA [inaudible]
in Southern Illinois or Ohio?
>> Yeah, that was in Ohio.
It was something like that, although
this place is much more finely tuned
than that.
>> Don't really need a
microphone to play in this room.
>> No, I didn't think so.
Yeah, I think you could have
done just fine without it.
>> No, but there's something about
the sound that makes that everything
that you do very present.
And I was interested that when
we played before the sound test,
I thought the sound would get
deadened when the audience came.
But the audience came and the
sound didn't get deadened.
Maybe the audience got deadened.
[ Laughter ]
>> Do you often do daytime concerts?
>> Yeah. When we can
wake up in time.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yeah, what do you
mean by daytime?
>> Well, it was a noontime concert.
>> In the crack of noon we play.
Man.
[ Laughter ]
>> How was the Millennium Stage
last night, how was your gig there?
>> It was great.
>> It was really good.
>> Yeah?
>> Yeah.
>> Great fun.
Yeah.
>> Strange auditorium and
there was no back wall.
>> Yeah.
>> It just goes.
>> There were all of
the people waiting
and drinking cocktails before
going to see Carmen at the opera.
And I think they were pretty
confused about what we were doing.
>> You know, they got
a little taste of opry.
>> Yeah.
>> We gave them some
opry before the opera.
>> Right. Different sound.
I mean, you really do need kind
of reinforcement I think
in that [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But the sound
was great there too.
>> Was your setlist today the
same as what you played last week?
>> It overlapped.
It certainly overlapped.
>> But there's several things
that we had never done before,
or never done them that way.
>> Well, I can go through
the set real quickly,
because I have some questions
to fill in the blank spots.
I really love it that you all talk
about the songs and introduce them,
and give some background,
which really works for us here
at the Library of Congress.
>> That's a big point of the show,
is to give a context to do that.
And my idea of the show was
to create a space for that.
>> You mean the roadshow?
>> Yeah, the roadshow.
The Treasures from
the Archive Roadshow.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, that's kind of a New
Lost City Ramblers things too
as well, isn't it?
>> I think so.
Do you think so?
To some extent.
>> We had to do it to
cover Tom's tuning.
>> Cold Aristocracy, where
did y'all learn that one?
>> Partly from the New
Lost City Ramblers.
Well, that's the first
time I heard it.
And then partly from
where you guys learned it.
>> Gantt Family.
>> Yeah, the Gantt Family.
>> No, no.
>> Charles Sieger [assumed
spelling].
>> Yeah, what is the name of
the family that recorded --
it's embarrassingly
escaping me at this moment.
But yeah, I first heard it from the
New Lost City Ramblers recording.
And then subsequently heard
the original field recording
that Charles Sieger made.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think on the last
record, the Ramblers that we did,
two or three or versions of it.
Our early version with
Tom, and then later
with Tracy, and then the original.
And they're all not the same.
But the strange thing about it is
that at some point, it left Ramblers
and became part of
Contra dance movement.
And so it's played
everywhere at Contra dances.
And it's probably different
from the one we play it now.
>> Taj Mahal plays it on the
banjo on one of his records.
It's real nice.
>> He has a nice version.
Yeah.
>> Just solo banjo piece.
>> Why did you choose
it to open the set?
>> Oh, I thought because
this is where it came from.
It's not the irony, the fact
that bringing it back
to where we got it from.
>> Yeah.
>> Although, you guys
never issued it.
>> No, you issued it.
>> Yeah.
>> It came from you.
>> Yeah, but how did we get it?
We got it because Mike
had it in his family.
So it's all very --
what's the word --
not introverted, intro
-- incestuous, that's it.
>> Incestuous.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yeah, Mike got a bootlegged
version of it and away we go, right?
>> Right.
>> I thought it was nice to
open with that in a sense
because of the connection
with the Ramblers also.
>> Yeah. And it's just a
great blastoff, you know.
It's such a great turn.
>> That's a tremendous tune.
When you hear the old
field recording,
you can't really hear
what's going on.
The recording is not clear,
but it's very powerful.
With a lot of old field recordings,
the recording is very powerful,
but it's not clear, you can't
hear everything that's going on,
so you have to make some choices if
you're going to play it live or now,
what are you going to do?
And that accounts in some
ways for the variations
that the New Lost City
Ramblers made or that we made.
We tried to record it a few years
ago and it's on one of our CDs.
And we tried to somehow
get at the sound
of the original field recording.
You know, and you start doing
some weird stuff sometimes to get
at the sound, but maybe
they were doing weird stuff.
>> Well, when the Ramblers did
it, we'd go to the relative minor,
a certain huge amount, or too much.
And that's what got picked up
in the Contra dance movement.
So then I just got the mandolin
and just -- don't change chords,
just stay on the one chords.
And it adds a lot of tension.
>> Yeah, without going
into the [inaudible].
>> The fiddle is going
into the minor.
>> Yeah.
>> But the accompaniment is not.
>> So what's it like when --
I assume you guys are
playing by yourselves.
And then you have to make room
for the guy who just wants
to play one chord on the
mandolin over and over again.
How do you do that?
In rehearsal, do you work it out or
you just make it happen on stage,
or how do you make
room for John Cohen?
>> They don't listen.
That's the best way.
>> Yeah. I mean, a lot of
people maybe people think
that old-time string bands don't
rehearse or something, but we do.
I mean, we make arrangements
of our songs.
I think all old-time
string bands did.
I mean, of course there's
spontaneity or maybe you just arrive
at a gig without having
rehearsed and just go for it.
Obviously that happens.
But it's important to remember that
there is like, arrangements going
on and conscious choices.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I think in a lot of ways,
the guitar part carries that tune.
Maybe I'm hearing the
field recording,
but I was really listening
-- you were playing guitar.
Yeah.
>> I don't think you
can hear the guitar
on the original field
recording, if there is one.
>> Yeah, I don't know
if there is one.
>> Do you recall?
>> I think there's a
mandolin that carries it.
>> Yeah, you can maybe hear
something like a mandolin.
It's pretty obscure.
>> OK.
>> But it's nice with guitar.
No, but the guitar adds so
much, so it's interesting.
>> Yeah.
>> So Oh, Mary, Don't
You Weep, Don't You Moan;
where did you get that one?
>> I've heard different
versions of it.
>> The version that we do,
there's numbers of versions of it
in your collection,
including some nice ones
from Newport Folk Festival.
But our version actually
is a version of a version
that we got off a 78
somewhere I think, right?
>> Yeah, the Georgia
Yellow Hammers do it, right?
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Yeah, a band from Georgia
called the Yellow Hammers.
And they did like, a lot of like,
string band arrangements
of old songs.
They seem like less of a dance band,
they don't really play dance tunes
as much, but they do kind
of old minstrel songs
really, and just have --
>> Interracial band.
>> Yeah, they pull music from --
>> Were they an interracial band?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, they played with a
duo called the Baxter Brothers,
who was an older man
playing the fiddle
and his nephew; Andrew
and Jim Baxter.
And they were Black.
And they recorded a dance
tune with the Yellow Hammers,
though it just says the
Georgia Yellow Hammers
because the recording industry
didn't like integration.
But you can hear that
integrated sound in a lot
of the Yellow Hammers' music.
And I'm drawn to that a lot.
And we like to do that
kind of stuff.
>> And for me, it's fascinating
because Lead Belly
recorded it as well.
And I think when I first heard
folk songs, which would be 1948,
at Woodstock, New York, and
this guy Rod Hill sang Oh, Mary,
Don't You Weep as part of
the group singing thing.
And then you'd hear it
sung at summer camps.
I was going to ask the audience,
how many of you folks heard this
at a singalong at a
campfire with marshmallows?
[ Laughter ]
>> I don't know where
that video comes --
there's a really early video from
maybe the 20s or 30s of like,
some guys, like five people
sitting out in the field.
Do you know the one
I'm talking about?
One guy is just playing tenor
banjo, and they all sing.
>> It may be a [inaudible] short
that they would have played
before a feature in the 20s.
>> Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] released a collection
that has some incredible footage
including this band that's like,
a real string band.
>> They sang the song?
>> Yeah, and it was great.
That's the first time I think I
heard an old recording of that song.
Saw it on YouTube.
>> Saw it on YouTube.
How about Justice Begley
[assumed spelling]?
That was nice pulling that
out from 1937 Kentucky.
>> Yeah. I love that recording.
I kind of came up with my own
version based on that recording.
And the lyrics to that song
have always intrigued me.
So I just kind of wanted
to make it my own.
>> Can you talk about
how you do that,
how would you make it your own?
What's different about
yours and his?
>> I guess because he does a
picking style on that recording,
and I changed it just
to claw hammer.
So that's one way that I arrive
at new versions sometimes,
is just translating
a different style
of picking or something to a song.
And then it just becomes totally
different from the original version.
>> I remember I once
pursued Alan Lomax.
I mean, I didn't I run after him.
But he had all of these
wonderful recordings
from Kentucky '37 and '39 maybe.
I said, "But I don't know
anything more about the musicians.
You never interviewed them,
you didn't write about them."
He says, "Because I was under
pressure from the Library
of Congress to make more, they
wanted more and more recordings.
So I didn't have time to."
Which is fascinating because
some of those recordings,
the ones that stimulate us the
most, have some of the most active,
lively stuff from Kentucky.
And the bureaucratic
decisions that had the pressure
on the Alan not to spend more time.
So we don't know anything
more about Justice Begley.
So how do you know
that he was a sheriff?
>> You told me.
>> Oh, OK.
[ Laughter ]
>> I must have read it in the notes.
>> Oh, there's a great
picture of him where he's --
>> There's some information about
him, but yeah, it's not a lot.
>> We have a folder on him.
You're welcome to check it out.
And I'll say with this,
the '37 Kentucky stuff
is about to go up online.
We're working with Berea
College and University
of Kentucky to put it all up.
And so pretty soon you'll be able to
stream all of your Justice Begley.
>> Are you trying to
put us out of business?
[ Laughter ]
>> So a little clear rock.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Nice.
>> Thank you.
>> Sugarland.
I think he was at Sugarland.
>> Right. Yeah.
He says it, I think,
at the beginning.
>> Do you know where you got
a hold of that recording?
>> It was --
>> Don't say document records.
>> I don't know if it was.
[Inaudible] like the
Black Texicans thing.
>> Yeah.
>> So it was the Rounders.
>> Yeah, Rounders.
Yeah, the Black Texican compilation.
>> Did Alan ever sing that song?
I've got a hunch he did.
>> Alan Lomax?
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know.
>> Every once in while he'd try
to sing from the Texas sessions.
It was both really
exciting and kind of scary.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yeah, I love those songs.
I think he also recorded that
I heard, what song was it?
Oh, yeah. He also recorded
Barbara Allen,
which I thought was
really interesting.
Right? I think he does it.
Yeah. He recorded a
version of Barbara Allen,
which I thought was
really interesting.
I don't know.
>> Yeah. I guess between
he and Ironhead Baker,
there was a big repertoire there
that the Lomaxes recorded
again and again.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm interested in
this Stone's Rag.
>> Stones Rag.
>> That was a new one for me.
>> Right.
>> Where did that one come from?
>> That's another one
off an old commercial 78,
but it got into the library through
the Ramblers, as far as I know.
Who did that?
Do you recall?
Where did we get that?
>> Paul Womack and his string band.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't think they recorded
very much, maybe only one record.
>> Where would you
have got that, John?
Where did the Ramblers get that?
You would have heard it from
a collector or something?
>> Yeah, we collected
from collectors.
But I remember when the Ramblers
did it, it was a big show tune
because Mike was playing harmonica
and autoharp at the same time,
and they were all driving
it very hard.
Because we had used it to break
up the monotony of our set.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I mean, you all did that
to an extent in the instrument swap,
which could be a comedy routine,
as I'm sure it is sometimes.
>> Yeah.
>> But that also seemed to be
a hallmark of the Ramblers,
the changing instruments.
Is that something you've
always done?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. We all play
a few instruments
and we all play them a
little bit differently.
Or you might come in to our
rehearsal or band practice
with an arrangement in mind and
you want to play instrument,
which forces somebody else to play
a different instrument or something.
However it shakes out, end
up switching instruments.
>> I've been fascinated
with the idea
of each chair has an instrument,
then we have to move
around chair to chair.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yeah, I would do that.
>> John, where did
you [inaudible] that?
Was that just a function
of your own musicianship
or is that a string
band tradition as well?
>> No, I think because
essentially, in a way,
these guys have been more
themselves the Ramblers.
They're like a library.
So we couldn't separate the song
from the sound that we heard.
And so to make it come
into existence,
it was like you had
to get to the sound.
It wasn't just another tune, it was
this instrument with that quality.
The same group of us, if
we do a Charlie Poole song,
we all change our style a little
bit, and it fits together.
But those guys in the old
days on the old record,
they didn't switch styles like this.
>> I think also part of
us does do that, though.
Because we'll take, yeah, and
old song that is from a record
and sounds a certain way,
and sometimes we'll just play
it a little more like we play.
I think there's both.
>> Well, I've been a bad
influence on you guys.
>> Right.
>> Well, even before you were here,
you know, they just played tunes
and they sounded like --
what did we call them?
The Dustbusters.
>> Right.
>> It sounded like the Dustbusters.
And then I came along, now they
sound like the Down Hill Strugglers.
>> Well, on the other hand, the New
Lost City Ramblers always sounded
like the New Lost City
Ramblers, despite --
>> That's not an insult.
[ Laughter ]
>> Well, just for the record,
whose instrument was whose?
I'm trying to figure out.
I couldn't figure it out.
You know, obviously you're
playing your fiddle, I get that.
That was probably your little --
was it a [inaudible] or something?
>> A lot of the instruments are
mine, the guitar and the banjo,
and the mandolin, and the
banjo ukulele were mine.
>> If he left the band,
we'd be in serious trouble.
[ Laughter ]
>> Or you could just
leave instruments
in different cities and --
>> That would be nice.
>> -- you wouldn't have to travel.
>> Like Chuck Berry.
>> Then we could hitch.
>> Buffalo Skinners, that's
a pretty straightforward one.
I want to talk about
Rolling Mills a little bit.
And you suggested, John,
when you made the field,
this is a John Cohen
field recording, right?
You learned from it.
And I think you said that you
hadn't heard any other recording
of that particular song.
>> Right. And until I had been
singing it, most people said
that they never heard
any other versions of it.
At lunch just now, we were talking
about other songs that have mention
of Rolling Mills, but none of
them had that strange story.
Actually, somebody after
the show asked me about was
that a metaphor, or
how does that fit?
How does the Rolling Mills fit into
this guy wanting to blow his brains
and his girlfriend is
pregnant and all of that?
He sings about it, you know,
"Put a bullet through my head,"
and all of that kind of stuff.
And then he sings, "The
rolling mills are burning down,
and they'll never bring
them back anymore."
So it's some really strange,
beautiful, poetic correspondence.
But I really like the fact
that you can't pin it down.
It's so good that you
can't pin it down.
It's better that way.
>> Yeah.
>> The tuning?
What was the tuning?
>> You take a regular old
D tuning, you run this --
>> You tuned it, didn't you?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I can do it, but
I can't remember the names.
>> Well, I can just say
quickly, yeah, that the tuning
for Rolling Mills is
the F sharp DEAD tuning.
F Sharp, D-E-A-D from
fifth down to first.
As John was saying,
it's like a D tuning
but with a third string
at E instead of F sharp.
OK, that's all I've got to say.
>> Is it the third string or the
second string that you run down?
>> It's the third string, I think.
>> Whatever it is, you get a bass
note which you wouldn't otherwise.
And you can also do a hammer on.
You hit that open string and you can
strike down on it so you get more --
I used to think that these guys
like George Landers' banjo tunings
and his tunes were some
of the strangest little
turns and twists in them.
But the more I live with that and
listen to the way he sings them,
he's describing what he's singing.
He's describing all of the
turns and twists in his voice.
If you listen to his
Cumberland Gap, he plays it three
or four different ways,
and it makes sense.
It's not like -- you know
what I'm talking about?
It's like he takes the idea that's
within the song or within his voice,
and makes it come out on the banjo.
It's a sound thing.
>> Yeah. Now, have any of you
learned that song from John
and can play it yourselves?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, I can't.
>> I never heard that.
>> I can.
>> That would be cool
if we could all play it.
>> Or just have it just play
simultaneously [inaudible] turned
away from each other.
[ Laughter ]
>> Leather Britches.
Nice quip on that one.
[ Laughter ]
Let's move on.
>> Right.
>> Moonshiner.
Yeah, that's Daw Henson, right?
You're saying that really
low in your register.
Have you always done it that way?
It's really low.
>> I think back in the day when
I first was attracted to it.
You know, I'm surrounded
by Mike and Tom and Tracy,
and they all have high voices.
And Roscoe has a higher voice.
[Inaudible], hey, a low voice.
>> Daw Henson.
>> And I have a low voice.
But I haven't don't it for so many
years, and so I was very nervous.
These guys were telling
me it sounded good,
so I might do it again.
But it's even hard to remember
how I tuned it back then
or how -- it's retuning.
And it's got an incessant,
insistent beat.
It close to Daw Henson's, but I can
see where I don't do what he did.
I found some other
thing to do with it.
But it's totally in
respect to what he did,
which is like I can say I can't
do what he did, but I can try.
I said try.
>> Similar to what you were
saying about George Landers,
how his vocalization and
everything reflected the song,
I felt like that was your
performance of Moonshiner,
it was right for -- I've
never heard it like that.
It was right for the song.
I thought it was great.
>> I mean, years ago, I
think I said it on the stage
that Bob Dylan had told me how
much he liked my version of it.
And I didn't remember
that I recorded it.
Which means that in '62
when Bob came to New York,
and that's when I recorded it,
that he must have heard
our records from back then.
>> Yeah. What about this fiddle
tune you got from Clay Walters?
Was that the Riding
Cowboy or something?
>> Yeah.
>> Is that the right name?
>> Yeah. Well, that's the name.
I know it's an accurate name.
>> OK. Because I couldn't quite
remember if it was Walters
or Williams, or Watson,
or something like that.
I think it's Walters.
But yeah, he sings just on the
company, and it's a beautiful,
I mean, it's kind of a cowboy
song really, it's more just kind
of a being away from home song, but
you know, with the cowboy all in it.
And then Frank Jenkins, who was
a great banjo player and fiddler,
there's a record of him
fiddling that and singing.
But Clay Walters has
some different words
that Frank Jenkins doesn't,
so I sing it like him.
>> Nice.
>> And some of those words enter
into Roscoe Hawkins'
[assumed spelling] song,
Cross the Rocky Mountain.
"I'll never get my mother's looks.
God bless her sweetly smile.
And even across the Rocky Mountains,
I walk from mile to mile."
>> Right.
>> So I'm getting a
hunch that Roscoe,
who said he wrote his version of
it, really picked it up from one
of these [inaudible] versions.
>> Right.
>> It came from a ballad
or something that he heard.
>> Yeah.
>> That's not surprising.
You ever dig into the
Luther Strong recordings
from Kentucky as well
and [inaudible]?
There's some amazing fiddle music.
I'm interested to hear the ones
that are being released are
Nathan Salsburg's Speed Corrected.
So I think for the first time,
I'm going to hear some of those
in a different way because
the electricity was bad
[inaudible] recording.
Maybe we'll learn whole new things
about [inaudible] or something.
>> Wow
>> I mean, I just remember this.
My brain retains things
in a strange way.
Because when I in Kentucky in
1959 and recording people there,
I didn't know who was coming next.
And there was this old guy, James
Crase who played the fiddle.
And he played some
pretty interesting,
weird tunings and odd timing.
Certainly in the back of my head,
the name Luther Strong came up,
and I had no idea why, because
I didn't look that carefully
at record labels back then.
So I said to him, "Did you
ever hear of a Luther Strong?"
"Oh, we played a lot of fiddle
contests, me and Luther."
Suddenly it was connected.
And I didn't know how my brain could
remember this guy playing a sound
and my brain connected it to
the Library of Congress record.
I don't know, to me, it's a wonder.
>> The Battle on the Horseshoe.
You played banjo.
That was nice.
You talked a lot about
where you got it.
You gave a plug to Sidney
Robertson and that was nice.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Because I think that
may have been the trip
where she was driving
for John A. Lomax.
>> She was?
>> On one of those
trips, she was his driver.
And two different people never
sat in a car for that long.
So that would have been interesting.
>> Should have made
field recordings of that.
>> I almost interrupted,
but I thought the thread
of your thought was
much more interesting.
But she married Henry Cowell, who
among other things, was the editor
of the International Folk
-- material on folkways.
But he's also a student
of Charlie Sieger's back
in Berkeley back in 1910.
And he also became
John Cage's teacher
because he explored
banging on the piano.
So you have experimental music and
you have all of these things kind
of flowing together rather than
being in separate categories.
I love that fact, you know,
how these things overlap.
>> No, we shouldn't overlook that.
And I mean, if one were to
describe your career, John,
I would say here's a man who
takes different disciplines
and different aspects of disciplines
and somehow makes them one,
makes them -- you're a disruptive
force for positive change
in the world through your art.
>> Yeah, but I'm surrounded by
three other guys who are that way,
they just haven't let
it come out as much yet.
>> No, I know Eli, and
I know he's the same.
Oh, let's see.
Wait, he puts on a folk festival,
he works for the record label.
>> True.
>> He performs, he produces records.
I'm going to guess that you guys are
similarly diverse in your approach.
And why is this?
What are you doing all of
this different stuff for?
Are you high?
>> Yeah. Good question.
For the money.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yeah. No, I've always just
wanted to try to create change
in the culture of New York City.
I always wanted to -- see, the
kind of stuff I do, I always wanted
to have a space for that and see
that happening, so I
just did it myself.
And I've been working on it for
about ten or 15 years at this point.
And during that period,
I have seen a change.
When I was growing up,
there was not much going
on in the mid to late
90s/early 2000s.
And now there's quite a nice quote,
folk music scene going
on in New York.
We have the Brooklyn Folk
Festival that I do with the people
at the Jalopy Theatre,
the main venue there
in New York there, the Jalopy.
And then I also put on the
Washington Square Park Folk Festival
when they expand up to Cambridge
and do a Cambridge Folk Festival.
The Jalopy has its own record
label that I've kind of taken
over at least at this point,
Jalopy Records, and we're putting
out this Library of Congress album
that's going to be very nice,
that'll be out in a few months.
Yeah, I mean, I have this band
and we go on tour and play.
There's very few touring string
bands, even in this day and age.
I mean, there's a lot of string
bands that play locally or just play
at home, or people
that go to festivals
and have huge just
a moment sessions.
But there's very few
touring string bands,
and there's very few
string bands that focus
on the songs to a large extent.
But the fiddle tunes kind of
took over and also got kind
of bastardized in some ways.
So that's part of what I
feel that we're trying to do,
is to bring the diversity
of the music,
and the songs also, out to people.
Because if you like music like this,
you don't get to see it
live really almost ever.
>> Yeah.
>> And people do now have
a chance in New York,
and that's thanks to Eli here.
There's a lot of people who play --
I mean, there are a lot more people
that I was ever aware of,
there are lot more people
in the country playing great
American music nowadays,
or maybe I've just gotten to
meet them in the last few years.
But you know, thanks to Eli,
people like them can get
work in New York at least.
So he's brought a lot of great
musicians to New York also traveling
for these folk festivals.
>> If you play music like we do,
it's possible to know almost
everybody in the country
that does more or less what we
do, and we know them pretty much.
>> I think so.
>> I hope there are more that
we don't, that would be great.
>> I think there are.
>> Well, because all of these people
that we're meeting
-- sorry, go ahead.
>> I'm always meeting new
people, even now that play.
>> And they're young.
Well, that's the thing.
>> There are people
coming up [inaudible].
>> We keep meeting like, 19- and
20-year olds that are really great.
>> Yeah.
>> But there's almost
no place to play.
There's no radio play, there's no
record companies, there's no --
>> That's kind of good.
>> -- festivals, there's no
infrastructure for the music at all.
Maybe that's good.
It's a mixed bag.
>> Well, the festivals is good.
>> But you know, I mean, in a
sense, maybe it's good and right
that the music should exist
below the radar of anything.
On the other hand, it's nice to
have it have some recognition
because without recognition,
people put it away or put it down.
>> Well, that's what so great
about today and yesterday.
>> Yeah.
>> Us and the Pope, I
mean, that's [inaudible].
>> And also to have, you know,
musicians want to play for people
and have access to playing at a
festival or something like that.
So that's in a big way,
that's what I'm doing.
>> And another really interesting
really component of this, you know,
Eli can talk about what he does
and you can talk about what I do.
But what these guy do, like after --
>> Yeah. Jackson, what
are you working on now?
>> Trying to learn a
bunch fiddle tunes.
I mean, I'm just playing the music.
I love it.
And then I make a living a
little bit repairing instruments
at Jalopy in New York.
So I spend some days
in the workshop there.
But yeah, just trying to keep
music at the center of my life.
>> Are you planning on
any recordings coming out
or anything people
can look forward to?
>> Well, it looks like we're
going to go spend some time
in New Orleans this winter
and hopefully record.
Just the three of us and
with some of our friends.
>> New Down Hill Strugglers
record will come out eventually.
>> Yeah.
>> And I play in a few other bands
in New York, just playing parties
and shows here and there, and all
kinds of music, like jug band music
and blues, things like that.
>> But Walker is also a
sculptor and a painter.
>> Used to be.
>> What?
Well, used to be means
might be again.
After we played in
Michigan recently,
I kind of did an ethnographic
study following these guys
around down the basement of a
video parlor, and all of those --
[ Laughter ]
>> -- pinball games and
all of the flashing lights.
>> I thought we were
just hanging out.
I didn't know you were up to that.
>> No, we hung out further than
I could hang out because I'm old.
But they're really
experts of hanging out.
We're too busy doing things.
They know how to hang out.
>> We play pool a lot.
>> You play pool.
>> What did you think of
Walker's Lost Indian, John,
the performance today of --
that's what it was called?
>> I'll leave for a second.
>> No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
>> Oh, the one that
came from Wade Ward?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, it was beautiful.
It was the only thing that
we played here that was soft.
In the whole set, it
was the only soft,
elegant music, and
I really liked that.
It made me feel guilty about all
of the hard stuff we were doing.
And it was a great honor to have
him pick up on that recording
that I had made of Wade Ward.
And then there was this subtle
remark about the change of titles.
>> I missed that.
Tell me.
>> Good. Well, just miss it.
[ Laughter ]
>> No.
>> Go ahead.
>> I don't know how it all
came about, but I was talking
to another great folklorist
and just amazing player,
Pat Conti, who lives in New York.
And he really digs deep when it
comes to finding out about sources
and just folklore basically
from back then.
And he said that tune
that John recorded,
which John calls Half Shaved,
is actually Lost Indian,
and that there's another banjo
tune by the name of Half Shaved --
>> That Wade Ward does.
>> -- that Wade Ward does.
And he played it for me.
I don't know where he heard
that, but it's in the same tune.
>> And the only reason
I call it Half Shaved is
because that's what Wade called it.
>> Yeah.
>> But Half Shaved is
only half the title.
And we tried to say where did you
learn it, but that [inaudible].
He learned it from his
brother who had learned it
from a guy from West Virginia.
So it's all over the map.
And I think it was Mike and
myself who reduced the title
to Half Shaved, and then
it took off as that.
And then Pat came and
[inaudible] proved us
to be falsifiers or
liars [inaudible].
>> Corruptors.
>> Corruptors, yeah.
>> But that's been going on
since the beginning, where a tune
or a song gets turned
into something else.
It's like the game, Telephone,
where you hear something different
and then it changes slightly.
I think that's like the folklore
tradition, as well as songwriting.
People sort of overlook that
there wasn't songwriting going on.
And fiddle tune writing as
well as learning from someone,
people were also creating.
So the tradition is to create
new things, in my opinion.
>> And you know, what's intriguing
about the tune is the way
that fifth string is tuned down.
>> Right.
>> It puts in a sound, it's a sound
that goes every way,
everybody plays it.
Because I think people, we're
attracted to it for the sound.
And the title is just
stuff you can talk about.
But the sound is what's special.
>> What's the tuning?
>> It's C tuning with the drone
string down to E, I think.
>> Run the strings for me.
>> E high string.
>> No, E, C, G, C, D. From
the fifth to the first, right?
>> Yeah.
>> OK. Nice.
I wonder if, you know, you're
a multi-instrumentalist,
and John says that you're also
a multi-format kind of person.
Does that help you be adaptable?
As you were saying, you're learning
new music, you're passing it on.
>> Yeah. The reason I brought
up songwriting and stuff,
I try to do that to like, write
new fiddle tunes and stuff
that comes directly
out of the tradition,
and have a totally new
song that sounds old.
It's fun to do that.
>> And then you've got
to sneak that stuff in,
otherwise people are
like, "Oh, a new tune."
You've got to sneak
it in so then it gets
into the drinking water,
and then people learn.
>> Well, I fear that we've
got our own momentum now,
and it's burying some of the private
things that each of us is doing.
But that's just an endless dilemma.
I know sometimes when Walker
plays his fiddle, [inaudible],
"Where did you learn
that," and he made it up.
And I say wow, that's just right.
I think there's a lot of
future with these guys
that hasn't been fully explored.
It will come out if
you last that long.
If you last that long,
I don't have to.
>> Katy Hill to end the
show, big rousing number.
[Inaudible] not quite
the same lineup
of instruments that
you started with.
So you've permuted to different
lineup from the beginning.
What's the source of Katy Hill?
>> That's a major national fiddle
tune, but in terms of at the Library
of Congress, Marcus
Martin recorded it.
>> Yeah.
>> There's another good
one that -- I'm sorry.
Yeah. But there's a
number of versions.
>> Well, I guess I meant what's
your version, do you know,
or is it just something
you've known for a long time?
>> I actually, somebody taught
that to me at a square dance
that I was playing this summer.
But I had heard the tune before.
>> And it's also known as --
>> It's also just like,
Sally Johnson.
>> Oh, Sally.
Yeah. And that's also in the
library under Sally Johnson.
>> The Reeds --
>> Henry Reed and Sally Johnson.
Yeah.
>> But yeah, it's just one of the --
>> It's a different note in
there that makes it [inaudible].
>> They claim they're different.
They're different.
>> The fiddlers will always
claim they're different tunes.
And I could show you
why they're different.
>> And the first time I ever heard
it was Mike [inaudible] was working
on his album [inaudible]
bluegrass style.
And just, "Come on, John, you
can play backup with this fiddler
in New Jersey, a guy
named Tex Logan."
And I had never heard
of bluegrass fiddling.
This was so fast, and
it was Katy Hill.
And Mike moving on the banjo,
and they were whirling.
"John, you play the
guitar behind it."
I didn't know what the
bluegrass licks were,
I didn't know any of that stuff.
So I was just winging
it on the guitar.
And I found myself doing
Riley Puckett runs,
which is from the Skillet Lickers.
>> And they do Katy
Hill pretty well.
>> Do they do it [inaudible]?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, yeah?
>> So they just figured you knew
a different version of it, right?
>> They say at the beginning
of the record, they say like,
"Some people call this Sally
Johnson, but down south,
we call it Katy Hill," and
then they kick into it.
>> Bill Monroe -- I'm not sure if he
recorded it, but he used to play it
on shows with a lot of drive.
So as a matter of fact,
the way we did it today,
and also Leather Britches,
to me, these guys together
with so much force into my ear,
that it's a fair match
for any bluegrass band.
The energy level that
we just get into.
But that's also a thanks
to the good sound
and good vibes from the audience.
If it's wet blankets, we
give them soapy towels.
[ Laughter ]
>> And then to everyone's
great surprise,
you pulled out Emmett
Lundy as the encore.
>> Yeah.
>> It seemed surprising
to you as well.
>> Because we had just played -- I
didn't know that these guys knew it,
and then we found it
out in the greenroom.
And it's a lovely, lovely tune,
and it's got great challenges,
all those beautiful
little notes in it.
I think we're going to
play it some more and more.
>> Yeah.
>> Emmett Lundy recorded as a
part of the road research project
in 1941 My Mother's Down in Galax.
I think that's where he got it.
That's a great unknown
body of material,
so thanks for bringing it up.
>> Oh, yeah, that's some
of my favorite stuff.
>> Yeah?
>> Yeah.
>> A member of the Lundy family was
here last week or the week before
as part of a symposium for Bell and
Reed, but I didn't get to meet them.
So what was the song title?
>> Ducks on the Mill Pond.
[ Silence ]
>> So is the roadshow over?
>> Oh, no.
>> I don't think so.
>> No, we'll be at Brooklyn
College on November 11th.
And onward into the future,
there's no reason to stop.
I'd like to bring it to more
colleges and universities.
It would be nice to reach
some college kids with this.
>> So you're happy
with a successful --
>> Oh, yes.
Yeah, it's been great.
And I credit you.
I think we were talking
when we thought of it.
>> Well, my idea was
slightly different.
It was a rolling thunder tour.
[Inaudible] get to play [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
I'm not getting credit for it.
>> I'm sorry, I didn't realize that.
I misinterpreted, man.
>> Now we've got to put the
Pope into this thing somehow.
>> When they asked us to move the
date of the show, I said, "Fine,
but where is the Pope," you know,
because I thought he
was going to be here.
>> They wanted him
to go to New York.
So when is your recording coming
out, the Jalopy recording?
>> It should be out early December.
I just sent it to the plant to
be pressed, so it'll be an LP.
>> Great. I look forward to that.
>> Yeah.
>> I always love those
Jalopy covers.
They look just like a 1960s --
>> Not to disappoint, this
has a different style cover.
But it's nice though,
it's modeled on some
of the old ethnic folkways
covers actually, if we're going
to keep quoting old record covers.
But yeah, the first two Jalopy
records and maybe future ones,
we'll keep stealing your design.
[ Laughter ]
>> What's funny is to sit
here in front of a crowd
and suddenly remember the
first LP from the Library
of Congress printed on red vinyl.
We used to hold it up to
the light and go, "Wow."
[ Laughter ]
>> You know, we have some of
those downstairs if you want
to have a look through them,
you know, anytime, John.
>> Yeah.
>> They can go to my house,
I've got them there also.
>> Walker, anything
coming up for you?
Are you doing any kind of --
>> Just the band.
We're getting more and more gigs.
>> How often do you guys play?
>> A lot.
>> It's been a busy summer for us.
>> Yeah.
>> So I got a part-time job
in the city that is good
because I can come and go.
Yeah, I think we're going
to go down to New Orleans
for a little bit, me and Jackson.
They've got that Black
Pot Festival in Lafayette.
>> Check out some Cajun
music and food.
>> Yeah, Josh Caffery is down
there doing some great work.
Make sure you check in with him.
>> It's going to be good.
>> John, what's cooking
with [inaudible]?
[ Laughter ]
>> [Inaudible].
It's funny, while we were
driving down yesterday,
and old friend called up,
"I just got your new
[inaudible] book, it's wonderful."
The one about Bob Dylan
and [inaudible].
I said, "Oh, no, that's the old one.
There's another one since then."
And the next one after that is going
to be about those years that I was
in Lower Manhattan in the
middle of the art world.
When I first came back from Peru,
I just settled on Third Avenue
between Ninth and Tenth
Street, because Robert Frank,
who wasn't that famous at
photography yet, he was a friend.
So I moved in next door.
And then you look around
and you find the whole
block is full of artists.
And then I looked into the history
of why there were so
many artists there.
First of all, it was cheap
rent, and the other was
that Willem de Kooning's studio
was right on the same block.
So the name of the new book
is Cheap Rents and de Kooning.
[ Laughter ]
But that's pretty much in the can --
it's not in the can,
where do they put it?
>> In the works.
The works.
And I'm going to try to do a lot
of drawing and get into my studio.
And when I get old, I'll
have something to do.
[ Laughter ]
>> And maybe a [inaudible] book.
>> Oh, yeah, and a book about
[inaudible] music in Peru.
I may go to Peru two weeks from now
for that film they're
making about me in France.
>> OK. Well, if you need
anybody to come along,
I'm sure you have other volunteers.
>> Get me a grant.
While you're out, get me a grant.
[ Laughter ]
>> Look, guys, I don't
want to hold you
up because I know you have
had a busy couple of days.
I just want to say once again,
thank you from the Library
of Congress for coming to visit.
And I hope this is just one
step along the way for us,
and that we'll continue to
influence each other and to build
on each other's work, because
it's a real exciting time.
And so thanks, guys.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.